next uh talk
i'm again delighted to uh introduce
kamelika chaudhry who
will be giving the talk kamlika was
unfortunate to be here in person
but unfortunately she got the flu
earlier this week so we're really glad
grateful that she can despite that she's
still
able to give a
talk through zom
um kamrika is a faculty member at ucsd
she works in the foundations of machine
learning
and she has done some amazing work she's
very highly regarded in her field and
just as an example of that she's
general chair this year of icml and has
been
program chair in the past like icml is
like one of the main international
conferences in machine learning
so
i will um
let kamalika talk more about her
research now
thanks uh thanks for the very kind
introduction i i am really bummed i
couldn't come um
you know i i wasn't in a condition to
travel
uh earlier this week but um yeah i'm
really bummed i miss this event because
it would have been my first kind of big
event in a very very long time
um
thanks
um
okay so uh i guess uh what i'm gonna
talk about is some of my uh recent
research in this direction of um trying
to understand adversarial robustness in
in kind of you know non-parametric uh
you know classifiers so what are
adversarial examples um well i think
most of you must have seen this uh this
picture right so
basically um you know what happens is on
the left you have this picture of a
panda and then what you do is you add
0.007
times the image on in the middle to it
right and what you get is this image on
the right and i don't know i mean at
least to me and i'm sure to most people
it looks like a panda but it turns out a
lot of the state-of-the-art neural
networks are completely convinced that
this is the gibbon and you know for
those who don't know because i get this
um question quite often a gibbon is a
type of monkey so um so all a lot of the
state of the neural networks are very
convinced that this is uh actually a
monkey
right
and so uh so what these are are
basically really small perturbations to
you know legitimate test inputs
and that causes um misclassification so
that is uh so so those these are uh
that's that's adversarial examples and
you know when we are talking about panda
and given you might be thinking that you
know this is a bit of a frivolous
example that you know oh well there was
a panda you misclassified as a given
what's the big deal
but
this can actually get quite serious
because you know if instead of uh
classifying pandas into difference if
you classified a stop sign as an ill
sign and you had that classifier in your
self-driving car
uh that that could be a more serious
things right that that could be a more
serious issue right so so as a result
what has happened is that a lot of work
has gone into you know over the last um
i would say five or six years uh a lot
of work has gone into trying to
understand you know adversarial examples
how they come from how to defend against
them and things like that okay
so what is known about adversarial
examples so
right now there's a very large number of
attacks so we know how to attack neural
networks very very well with like really
minor perturbations and not just neural
networks we know how to do attacks very
very well
um
there are also quite a few defenses um
that you know that work reasonably well
uh
with you know mixed success i would say
because sometimes they lead to loss in
accuracy but there are quite a few
defenses
um but at the time when we had started
looking at this and this was maybe a
couple of years ago so most of the work
that i will talk about has happened has
published has been published in the last
couple of years so this is about so we
started work uh working on this a few
years ago uh there wasn't a lot of
understanding on you know why
adversarial examples happen what's going
on how they fit into the framework of
learning you know traditional learning
theory and uh that's uh that's kind of
what i'll talk about today okay then why
why do adversarial examples happen
okay
uh so let me start with a bit of a
background so the kind of problems we
are looking at uh over here
is classification so what is
classification the idea is you know it's
very very simple it's uh you have these
x i y i pairs right x i's you know think
about them as vectors of features and y
is our discrete labels so you know these
labels could be uh panda uh versus uh
given or it could be dog versus cat or
there could be multiple labels as well
um right so there are a bunch of
discrete labels and your goal is to find
a prediction rule uh usually this is a
prediction between a particular class so
it could be a linear classifier or a
neural network and so on that would
predict the y's from the excess okay
and uh
in traditional learning theory is built
on you know what is called the
statistical learning framework or kind
of the back learning framework and here
what happens is that there is an
underlying data distribution right so
there's some underlying data
distribution d
and both your training and test data are
drawn from this underlying distribution
right and uh what happens is that what
you want to do is to find a classifier
that maximizes accuracy according to
this distribution so what is accuracy so
the accuracy is the fraction of um
examples that is drawn in a fraction of
labeled examples
drawn from this distribution where uh f
of x is equal to y right so um where you
are predicting the right label when your
classifier is predicting the right right
label right so this is your um this is
your accuracy and uh what traditional
learning theory has always done is it
has been uh focused on maximizing this
kind of accuracy
okay
so how uh how do we uh think about
robustness in this framework so when we
think about robustness uh what we are
going to do is we are going to add an
additional measure of robustness and we
say that a classifier is robust with a
radius s at a particular data point x
if for a distance metric d
if your distance between x and x prime
is less than equal to s then f of x is
equal to f of x prime right so what this
means is that
uh we'll be predicting so if you look at
your legitimate um
test input you would be predicting the
same label in a small ball of radius s
around this test input right so if you
you know if you uh going back to our
panda versus given example if you
imagine your panda to be this image
right and then a little bit around this
image in a small ball of radius uh uh
you know in a small ball around this
image you would be predicting panda
instead of predicting uh you know
predicting something else okay and if it
is robust with radius s at this
particular point x what this means is
that there's no adversarial examples
around x okay
uh how do we combine robustness and
accuracy so the way we would do this is
through um
a measure that we call astuteness right
and we'll say that um
you know if you are astute at uh at a
point x with a radius r means that you
are predicting the correct label at that
point and you are predicting the same
label in a model of radius r right and
so what we care about is um for robust
classification we don't just care about
the accuracy but what we care about is
acidness which is the fraction of points
where your classifier is both robust and
it's accurate and what we will try to do
in robust classification is maximize
astuteness instead of maximizing just
the plain accuracy okay
so that is our goal
okay so now let us uh build this
background in place let us come back on
uh why do we have adversarial examples
now if we go back to kind of uh you know
kind of classical learning theory and we
try to understand what might happen well
one of the possibilities is uh you know
we may have adversarial examples because
our data distributions um you know
either they're overlapped or they're
very close to overlapping right so maybe
pandas actually do look like gibbons
they're just you know a tiny bit
different and um and so
you can't have both robustness uh and
accuracy so this is one possibility
the other possibility is that maybe
pandas and gibbons they look very
different
but we don't have enough samples or
pandas
uh or enough samples right to be able to
tell them apart properly right so maybe
that's the reason uh why
we had these adversarial examples
and then the third possibility is that
we are using the wrong algorithms right
so once you have the samples of pandas
and gibbons what we are trying to do is
we are trying to find some classifier
which uh
you know which separates the pandas from
the givens which sets them apart
maybe what we are doing is we are using
the wrong algorithm to find this
classifier so there many classifiers are
possible and different algorithms will
give you slightly different ones maybe
what we are doing is we are using the
wrong classifier you know we are using
the wrong algorithm right so these are
the three possibilities and i'll give
you the answer ahead of time so the
answer is
basically three right
it's basically three and now for the
rest of the talk i will try to convince
you that three is really the answer okay
so um that's uh that's uh that's where
uh we are gonna go from here okay
okay any questions before i get to sorry
any questions before i uh get into more
details
okay okay so let's uh let's then uh go
ahead um a little bit and so the context
in which we will be uh looking at
these problems is in the context of
non-parametric methods so what are
non-parametric methods
these are these really simple uh kind of
classifiers uh you know kind of
pattern recognition methods that people
have been using for a long time so these
are you know things like kenya's
neighbors where the idea is that you um
you know you look at your closest
neighbors and then you predict the
majority label of these neighbors right
another example of non-parametric
classifiers are decision trees right so
based on data you build you know kind of
a rule tree of rules like this right
like the example on the slide
and uh
um and so these are two simple examples
but there are more complicated examples
as well so there are things like random
forests which are much more you know
which are much more complicated on
samples of trees or things like kernel
classifiers um so there's there's a
whole bunch of um
you know there's a whole bunch of
classification methods that fall into
this category of non-parametric methods
okay
so what is known about non-biometric
methods well um
before i get to that i need one last
definition which is that of the bayes
optimal classifier okay so what is the
base optimal classifier this is the
classifier which has the highest
accuracy on the data distribution
uh and it's uh you know notice that this
is
a function of the data distribution
so what this means is that you can't get
to it in the finite sample limit but it
is reachable only in the infinite sample
limit right so as you get more and more
samples you can get closer and closer to
the base optimal okay so it's a
distribution quantity and it's kind of a
limit you know distribution quantity
okay
so what is known about nonparametric
methods uh and this is due to a theorem
by stone in 1977
and what stone showed was that as the
training data size grows
the accuracy of many non-parametric
method
methods converge just to the accuracy of
the base optimal so you know things like
nearest neighbor decision trees and so
on if you construct them properly
uh
and there are some details that i am
ignoring a little bit over here but if
you construct them properly
as your data size grows
they would get closer and closer to the
base optimal right so in the limit in
the large sample limit they would be
doing uh you know they would be doing
the right thing
okay
uh well okay so this was for accuracy
but what about robustness so to look at
robustness let me start out with looking
at well separated data okay
so what do i um study what do i mean by
uh well separated data so it turns out
when we are looking at our robustness
the notion of robustness that becomes is
something called r separation right and
we say that our data distribution is are
separated if when you have two points x
y and x prime y prime
drawn from this distribution if y is not
equal to y prime then the distance
between x and x prime is at least twice
r right so what this means is that if
you have points with two different
labels they're at least distance to r
apart right and why is this definition
interesting so the reason why is
interesting is because
if this you know if your data
distribution is are separated
then there is a classifier
is um
astute at radius r right
so
it means that you know if your data
distributions are separated there exists
at least there at least exists a
classifier which is going to be astute
you know which will be um you know which
will have as units one at this kind of
radius r now whether we can find it or
not is a different matter but there
exists such a thing okay
uh and uh so now let's see for this kind
of r separated distributions if we can
have an analog of stone's theorem uh so
to uh to have an analog of stone's
theorem let us first try to understand
what could be the limit of uh robust
classification
so it turns out the first kind of
interesting thing over here
is that even if your data distribution
is are separated your base optimal will
not be the light right limit right to
understand this uh look at this kind of
toy example here your classes you know
you have these two regions which are
your pluses and minuses
if you look at these blue lines these
all these blue lines are base optimal
because the base optimal is undefined
outside the support after distribution
uh you know so that so long as you are
doing the right thing inside the support
in the outside the support you can do
anything
but if you look at these blue lines
these blue lines are actually not robust
because you know as you can see these
blue lines
they pass very close you know you can
see one of them passes very close to the
gray uh distribution so it's not going
to be robust and it turns out you can
actually define um
the right robust analog and this is
something that we call the r optimal and
this can be the cloud this can be
defined as the classifier that maximizes
the astuteness instead of maximizing the
uh accuracy okay
uh so what does it look like so it turns
out you can write down a formal
definition uh to give you some idea of
what it might look like here is an
example of what it might look like for
um a distribution that is are separated
right so you know so and and again this
is uh just like the base optimal the r
optimal is also not unique
uh but this will be an example
you predict plus if you are within
distance r of the support of the
positives and you predict minus
otherwise so you can show that this will
have at stiffness one
so it is a r optimal uh but this is not
necessarily d are optimal right like
there can be multiple are optimum even
for our separate distributions okay so
this is the right limit
and now the question is can we actually
converge to the r optimal
and it turns out uh sorry so it
there's something sorry something went
wrong with my slides
uh
sorry so the question is can we
sorry
uh converge to the r optimal sorry i i
should have um
yeah so uh question is can we converge
to our optimum uh and it turns out that
we can do it but let us start uh so to
understand when we can converse with our
optimal let us look at
maybe a couple of uh a little bit more
of notation
so um let us look at when uh how can we
represent this very general
nonparametric classifiers so it turns
out uh these non-parametric classifiers
that i just talked about they can be
represented as uh something called
weight functions and this is something
which was shown by stone um you know
this is uh essentially from stone's
theorem and what do weight functions
look like well weight functions look in
the following way for every x which is
um
a test point what you can do is you can
get a weight w s comma i of x right this
is the weight of x
uh
due to
um
you know
due to uh i
uh due to training point i in our
training set s right and what you can do
is you can write w s of x is the sign
off and here i'm talking about binary
classifiers summing over all your
training points uh i y goes from 1 to n
y i times w s of s comma i of x right
and it turns out many of your common um
non-parametric classifiers can be
represented in this form so for example
if you're talking about nearest
neighbors
wsi of x is one if x i is one of the you
know closest neighbors of x so if you
are doing for example one nearest
neighbor then this will be one if x is
the closest neighbor of x in the
training set s and it will be zero
otherwise right and then what you will
get over here is exactly the one nearest
neighbor classifier for decision trees
ws uh i of x could be one if x i is in
the same cell of the decision tree as
this point x right so you can represent
decision trees also in this particular
form right so this is kind of a general
form in which you can represent a lot of
these um non-parametric classifiers
and uh here is um
the main theorem of our paper so the
main theorem that we can prove
is your weight function your
non-parametric classifier represented as
a weight function will converge to the r
optimal if the following condition holds
right and the condition is the following
uh on expectation
you have this supremum over x prime
in a ball of radius uh a around uh you
know and this is for all a less than
equal to
um you know less than equal to b
supremum for x prime
uh
lies in a ball of radius a around x
uh sum of these weights right so sum
over
um i equal to 1 to n
the weights of um
you know this wsi of x prime
times
um
the fact that x prime you know times x
prime that lies outside a ball of radius
um b
goes to zero right so this is kind of
the condition so what does this
condition mean right so let's take a
quick look at uh what this condition
means
what this means is the contribution to w
uh s of x
right
from points that are not local to x
uh that contribution goes to zero right
and uh so what does this mean uh well
basically what this means is that as you
get more and more samples your
classifier becomes more and more local
right that's that's uh you know at a
intuitive level that's kind of what this
contribution is saying
and now if you look at the stone's
theorem condition the stone's theorem's
condition is also similar but the
difference between stone's theorem and
our theorem is our condition is a little
stronger our condition says this
not only for x's that are drawn from the
data distribution but also for
x prime
that lie uh close to those x's right so
stone's theorem means that this kind of
locality condition applies only to
the data points x that are drawn from
the distribution our theorem it applies
to not just those points but also other
points in balls of radius a around them
right that's kind of the difference so
our condition is a little stronger but
what is interesting is that because of
the strength
right that because of this extra
conditions it turns out that uh you know
we have some classifiers that converge
to the bayes optimal so that satisfy the
conditions of stone's theorem and so
they converge to the base optimal but
not to the r optimal right and it turns
out these classifiers are you know
histogram classifiers which you know the
decisions i've been using for a while
and decision tree classifiers which you
know most of us have heard about right
and so these are the so our result of
our theorem is that these classifiers
would converge to the bayes optimal as n
goes to infinity but it won't converge
to the r optimal right
what happens over there so to give you
some intuition
uh about what is happening over here let
us look at this example of decision
trees right so here what is happening is
you have the you know the red points and
you have the gray points right those are
your two classes and there are separate
did you can see that their distance are
apart right
and if you used a standard decision tree
algorithm to construct a decision tree
what that algorithm would do is it would
find a one node tree right a single node
tree which is uh represented by this
blue line that is your decision boundary
on one side you have gray on one side
you have red and what it would do is
because it has accuracy hundred percent
it would just stop right it would uh
stop at this point this is a decision
tree even if you had an infinite number
of samples it would not do anything more
right but on the other hand
there is a decision tree which
classifies these robustly it's this like
you know super zigzaggy decision tree
and i've tried to draw an approximation
to it
you know there's this uh zigzag uh black
line it's a super zigzaggy decision tree
um if you could get to that decision
tree then you would classify things by
you know you would classify things not
only would you classify them accurately
you would also classify them robustly
but the current decision tree algorithms
are not going to find it because they're
just going to stop when they hit 100
accuracy right so this is kind of what
happens and what you can see is uh you
know what i had claimed earlier um
that um here at least what is happening
is that the problem is the training
algorithm right so if you uh even if you
have an infinite amount of data even if
your data is are separated
um
even then things like decision trees are
not going to find the right classifier
and the reason for that is that we are
using the wrong algorithm
okay
so that's uh
what is going on with robustness any
questions at this point
um
okay
okay first question question okay
um i wanted to ask what is the
difference between your objective and
just maximal margin classifiers because
basically the classifier you showed
which which is optimal it's just the
maximum margin one right
or very close to it
yes that is you know that is in fact a
very very good question
uh in some sense we are not really
looking for max margin we are kind of
looking for a classifier which has
margin at least r
and in fact in the um
a little bit down the road we will make
um
a somewhat more formal connection and
we'll come back to that
that's a very good question thank you
one more question
hi so my
question was about this notion of
robustness i understand why
i imagine it
it would be good at stopping
the panda
given thing uh because the noise
is sort of uniform uh sort of makes
sense this sort of like
based on our
obviously like
normal mathematical notions of distance
but i guess my question is
does this robustness notion work for
like the don't stop sign thing where
like
it might be like high euclidean distance
uh but like there's some other notion in
some sense
in which like
oh this is still obviously a stock sign
does that sort of make sense
right all right no no it does uh it
definitely makes sense so in okay so uh
i guess there's a couple of uh uh
answers to this question and you know
it's a very good question thank you
um so one thing is that
to some extent understanding how to get
around this euclidean notions of
robustness can give us insights into how
to get around more complicated uh i i
absolutely agree with you right to get
around more complicated um notions of
robustness so a lot of these ideas um
and which leads to my second answer
which is people have tried to do
robustness in for example a feature
space right so instead of looking at
robustness in the ingredient metric
space what you could do is you can look
at the representation space
where you know kind of traffic signs
are kind of clubbed together and you
could also impose robustness in uh you
know in in a more complicated metric
space um
and a lot of the ideas that uh you know
a lot of the ideas actually go through
uh it's just much more expensive because
you know calculating that representation
is a lot more expensive but a lot of the
ideas that uh i and a lot of the
insights that we learned uh do go
through for those more complicated
notions of robustness
i don't know
but that totally answers my question ah
thank you
thank you
okay
so um
excellent so uh so so we talked about
robustness and we talked about how it
depends on the training algorithm
uh so and uh we looked at uh kind of the
well separated case now the question is
um what about the more general case when
your data is not well separated it might
be overlapping and so on
so in this case one of the first
questions here
is how can we define the r optimal right
like you know in this case um the
question you know because we had our
optimal we can talk about convergence to
it now the question is how do we
eventually find the r optimal right
so uh it turns out that you can do it
here um in the following way
so what you could do is um you know you
could do it here in the following day
suppose you have your robustness radius
r and suppose you have a classifier
which is predicting a label j in this
set s sub g and uh and it's doing this
robustly
then it turns out um that
you can uh write down the following
constraint right so if you have a
classifier which predicts label j in a
set of s sub j and is robust in the set
then the distance between you know some
s by and sub j has to be at least twice
r right otherwise you could not have
been robust there right so this is uh
you know you can write down these
constraints
then it turns out
if you are predicting uh robustly in um
you know you're predicting label j and
you're being robust in sfg then you can
also write down the astuteness in terms
of these sets s of j right and the acid
nest is uh you sum over all the labels
uh one to keep
and then you look at uh the following
right so you sum over all these labels
uh one to k and then for label j you
have set s sub g and within set as sub j
you integrate uh over the you know
you're basically integrating over
accuracy right how accurate are you in
this data subject subjected to the fact
that s by and sub j are distance at
least twice are apart right and you can
you know you can you can look at this
and this suggests the following uh limit
classifier right so what you do is you
look at these sets as sub j right
and you maximize this objective which is
the assetness um
over the sets subject right so uh
so given a robustness radius r
you pick s sub j to maximize the
objective and objective is your
assetness subject to the constraints
that the distance between sub i and s of
j is at least twice r right so if you
could solve this optimization problem
it's a really complicated optimization
problem because uh you know your
variables are you know all subsets of
your instance space right and these
could be really really complicated
subset but if you could solve this
optimization problem uh
then you would have your uh classifier
and your prediction rule would be
you predict label j if you are within
distance uh r
of this set s as subject right so if you
could solve this then you would get your
um classifier and that would be your r
optima okay
so this will suggest the classifier now
the question is okay so now we have a
limit in theory the question is how can
can we somehow approximate this limit in
practice right how can we get some sort
of
actual real classifier that converges to
this limit
and it turns out um
you can if you um you know you can at
least get one approximation if you think
about representing
each set s sub g
by a subset of training samples
and it turns out that
it leads to a very simple combinatorial
problem so your really complicated
optimization
will become uh you know if your s j
instead of being arbitrary subsets of
your instance space if there are a set
of samples it turns out uh this will
become the following it will become the
you know it will basically reduce to
finding the maximal subset of training
samples where points with different
labels are distance to our or more apart
right this will be
your commentary of the problem
and then
um you know how can you solve this well
one way to solve this uh so it turns out
that for a binary this will reduce to
maximum bipartite matching with a little
bit of math this will reduce maximum
hypertype matching so you can uh you
know you can construct a graph and then
find the matching in the graph that will
give you this subset of samples
for krd uh you know if you are looking
at instead of binary classification or k
levels then it will reduce to
independence at you know of course this
is uh you know hard to approximate and
how to solve in many different ways but
you can at least use a greedy algorithm
for it
and so your algorithm will become the
following and we call this adversarial
pruning your algorithm will become you
have your trading set you find the
maximum subset of trading samples where
point the different labels are distance
to r or more apart right so you find
this subset of your trading set and then
you build your favorite classifier on it
right you can build nearest neighbors
decision trees random forest whatever
your favorite nonparametric classifier
was you can build uh this classifier on
it and it turns out the surprising thing
is um if you call so this is uh you know
this we call this adversarial pruning so
if you can if you combine this
adversarial pruning plus something like
nearest neighbors or kernels which
actually worked on well separated data
then
we can also converge to our optimal in
the large sample limit and this is a
little bit surprising because
now you know after adversarial pruning
your training set has all manner of
dependencies it's not an independent
training set anymore but it turns out
that at least in the large sample limit
you can still get this kind of
asymptotic convergence
and it turns out it also works
reasonably well in practice so we did
some experiments with them
and uh it does hold up right like you
know removing this kind of uh you know
taking away data doesn't hurt things too
too much and you can actually do this
and
it also works reasonably well in
practice okay
okay any questions so far uh before i
move to my third part where i will talk
about connections to max margin
kind of like two related questions is
how do you decide which um subset to
prune like if there was a s4 that's kind
of superimposed on s1 do you like get
rid of all the s4 points that are within
a radius of s1 points or do you get rid
of the s1 points that are within the
radius of the s4 points
uh so um
what you would do here is you would
build a graph
where i think um uh
what what you would do here is you would
build a graph where two points if they
are
um you know within distance r
uh and have different labels then you
are connecting them by an edge and then
you find the maximum independent set in
the graph so um i guess what would
happen would depend on the relative
sizes of s4 right like removing s4 you
may end up removing a lot of points in
which case you wouldn't um
so that's that's kind of the main idea
sorry this also has a follow-up question
um so then with like uh with inputs like
image or text like
would this depend on which
representation like you decide to use to
get the x's so like would you want to
like
uh would would this be just much harder
for certain representations than for
others and how do you like i guess
incorporate that
yeah that's a very good question so here
uh i i should have mentioned this the
distance metric that you would use when
you build a graph right when points
within distance uh twice are connected
right the distance metric would be the
distance in which
you are uh measuring adversarial uh
robustness right like you know if you
remember for adversarial robustness you
have a metric right that within balls of
radius r you should be predicting the
same thing these two should be the same
metric so um yeah so for some metrics
you know if you it's a very complicated
representation and then you are looking
at distance in that metric then uh yes
calculating that metric itself is really
hard uh but then
once you have the graph
uh
you know then then you can apply the
combinatorial algorithm on top of it
thank you
okay thanks uh
okay so uh so in conclusion for this
part we looked at this r optimal uh
which was um a large sample limit for a
robust classification and then we showed
conditions under which um you know
classifiers converge to this limit and
then we found that things like nearest
neighbors and kernels converge for well
separated data
but not things like decision trees and
then for non-separated data we looked at
adversarial pruning which would remove a
bunch of the data points and then um
we showed that this work and you know
kind of the conclusion at least for um
non-parametric methods is that the
training algorithm is uh what is to
claim okay
now
let us think about uh how we define
robustness right like when we get back
let us think about how we define
robustness um so you know given the fact
that we are looking at our robustness
you know we know what to do uh at least
in the larger limit because the question
is does this in fact give us the most
robust solution okay
to understand if that is the case uh
let's look at an example
of uh what happens when your data is
heterogeneous and this this does happen
a fair bit in practice when uh you know
the the scales ah
you know if you if you have
heterogeneous data the scales in one
region of space uh you know distances in
one region of space is quite different
from the distances in another region
right
so if you look at this example over here
what is happening is your class uh your
red class is kind of multimodal right
um you know there are two small clusters
of red and gray which are somewhat close
and then there is a large cluster of red
a long distance away so think about you
know i don't know maybe uh the reds and
grays over here are like cats and dogs
and then the other red is some very kind
of unusual kind of cats like maybe
tigers right which look quite different
right
and so what would happen if you are
trying to do robust classification in
this case
well what might happen is because of the
way we formulated the problem and we
chose this one radius r
we may end up with lacking both accuracy
and robustness right
so for example if you look at these blue
decision boundaries if you look at the
blue decision boundary where we are
trying to get to you know you have some
radius r and you are trying to get to
the r optimal here you are sacrifice if
you are looking at the left where the
the red clusters and the gray clusters
are closed
you are sacrificing uh accuracy for
robustness right you may be able to get
robustness but you may be sacrificing
accuracy because you can't get both at
once
whereas if you are looking at uh what is
happening to the right
you know your
your blue line it's also not giving you
the most robustness because it's much
closer to the gray part than to the red
part on the right right so you are uh
you know because of the way you
formulated the problem you are getting
neither accuracy and or not robustness
right whereas if you looked at this
green solution
uh then this green solution knows that
when you know it's it's kind of a data
dependent uh notion of robustness right
so this green solution knows that um you
know when you are uh in the in the left
part of space close to
uh you know where the clusters are
closed you should go through the middle
so you should get accuracy and sacrifice
robustness whereas on the other part of
the space you should be more robust
right in some sense this is what a max
margin style classifier would do
when it can it should get robustness
when it can it should get the most
robustness it can manage to get
whereas
when it is in a part of space where the
clusters are close together it should
try to get accuracy and sacrifice
robustness right so
how can we get to this kind of data
dependent notion of robustness right and
how can we formulate robust
classification to address this
and it turns out that we can do
something in terms of um you know in
in the context of these non-parametric
classifiers okay
so how can we formulate such a thing
so before we get to how to formulate it
let us maybe look at a couple of
conditions you know like what are some
of these ideal conditions that the
formulation should satisfy right
so one ideal property that we
would like to have is at least uh that
we shouldn't have much of a robustness
accuracy trade-off right like you know
we should try to get accuracy when we
can
and then you know we should try to get
robustness uh as we can right so there
shouldn't be a robustness accuracy
trade-off
right the second condition is that we
should try to get some sort of
data-dependent robustness in the sense
that we should try to get more
robustness when the data is better
separated and not yeah and maybe not as
much when data is not well separated
and finally we should try to get
something
that is at least achievable
by you know some of the existing
algorithms it doesn't have to be the
case but you know ideally we should try
to get something that is achievable to
either some of the existing algorithms
or maybe some modifications to the
existing algorithms right so these are
some of the properties that we would
like to have okay
so um
recall in the standard learning setting
so let's let's now start out with uh
trying to see
if we can get uh you know like a large
sample limit object which does that
right in the standard learning setting
what we were trying to do is we were
trying to maximize accuracy
and the large sample limit that we had
was the bayes optimal classifier which
uh maximized accuracy on the
distribution okay
now in the our robustness setting what
we did was we went from accuracy to uh
you know we changed our limit uh we were
trying to maximize assetness and this
gave us the r optimal classifier right
where we maximized robustness within
radius r okay our acid is within radius
r
and it turns out
and you know as we saw that that is also
not enough and it turns out that we can
in fact extend this idea
and we can get to a different notion of
a limit object which we call the
neighborhood optimal okay so what does
the neighborhood optimal do
within the support of the data
distribution it's going to predict with
the bayes optimal right so
inside the support of your data
distribution it does exactly what the
base optimal does okay
and outside of the support what it's
going to do is it's going to predict
with the
um
base optimal
of the closest point in the support
right so if your point is inside the
support you're done you just go with the
business optimal if your point is
outside the support you find your
nearest neighbor in the support
and then you do what the base optimal
does inside that point right and this is
what we call that neighborhood optima
okay
so um
so essentially what we are looking to do
over here
is you are looking at for a point x
inside the support of your distribution
your robustness region are the points
that are closer to x
than to the support of a different label
and what you're trying to do is you're
trying to get accuracy right inside your
support you get accuracy and yours
you want to predict
you want to make the same prediction in
the robustness region of x
for x that are drawn from this data
distribution right so
you get accuracy you know accuracy you
try to maximize as much as you can and
then outside the support you just
predict with uh you know
you just make the same prediction as the
um
as in the robustness region right so
that is uh that is the that is the main
idea okay
now let's see if this uh at least this
limit object satisfies our conditions it
will satisfy no robustness versus the
accuracy tradeoff because remember
accuracy
you only care about accuracy in the
support of the distribution and you
always agree with base optimal in this
support right so it's not going to
sacrifice accuracy
it will give you data dependent
robustness and in fact if you look a
little bit more closely at this example
that i talked about where there are two
closed clusters and one cluster that's
far apart it's going to do absolutely
the right thing right because you know
the clusters that are close together
it's going to sacrifice you know within
the support it's going to do what the
base optimal does so it's going to you
know focus on accuracy whereas if you
were looking at the region you know kind
of the region on the on the right
then it is going to go through the you
know then it's going to kind of um
predict with the nearest neighbor and if
you look at the decision boundary
basically it's getting uh you know it's
going to go um you know
go max margin in that area okay
and then
uh is it achievable by existing
non-parametric algorithms uh let's let's
look into that okay
and it turns out it is in fact
achievable uh and in fact under some
conditions uh many non-parametric
methods would converge to this
neighborhood optimal in the last sample
limit and you know we can show an analog
of the
theorem that i had uh talked about
earlier
and it turns out again the conditions
are stronger than uh what we had before
so nearest neighbors and kernels would
converge uh with some
slightly more stronger conditions
uh but then you know again things like
decision trees or histograms they are
going to converge to the base optimally
you know they will follow stone's
theorem but they're not going to
converge to this uh this particular
formulation
right they're not going to converse to
the neighborhood optimal and you know
this is kind of to be expected okay
so in summary uh we can get a data
dependent formulation robustness
and uh you know if you
look at uh what our
you know what our formulation does uh is
um
in comparison with the standard
formulation and our robustness what we
are trying to do is we are trying to get
accuracy plus a particular form of max
margin robustness
okay
uh in the large sample limit for
standard we had base optimal for our
robustness we had our optimal our
formulation the optimal is something we
call a neighborhood optimal and if you
look at algorithms
uh in the standard case you know things
like k nearest neighbors kernels and
decision trees that would all go to the
base optimal
for our robustness you would need to do
this kind of adversarial pruning
followed by things like k-nearest
neighbors or kernels where as in our
case you don't need to do the pruning at
all standard cadent nearest neighbors
and kernels will converge to this
neighborhood optimal in the large sample
limit okay
and so in conclusion we looked at a new
formulation with uh you know which
of data dependent robustness which
resolves some of the issues that are
present in the standard formulations uh
we also showed that things like nearest
neighbors and kernels will converge to
it in the uh in the large sample limit
uh and the open question here is um you
know are there better formulations right
are there are there more optimal
formulations um you know are there
better formulations and you know this
entire space is really open of uh you
know how to define and get to data
dependent robustness okay
uh so finally you know these are our uh
references and i will finally end with
the pictures of my collaborators and
students uh who did a lot of the work
thank you
any questions
okay so then
this is the panda now is it still a
given or does it when you apply it uh
your work
like in an example like that
so a lot of the standard neural network
defenses like adversarial training
it will stop the panda from being a
given
but there are very very good attacks
that you can use to get around it
because you know for neural networks
everything is np hard so you can't
really
give
guarantees uh but they are you know i
mean there are better and better attacks
coming up so they they are still
attackable
one more question yes
i'm wondering do you try to formalize
like how hard it is to achieve
robustness based on how many points you
had to prune
[Music]
no that is a very good question so what
you are saying is you could measure
maybe
maybe you could give some estimate of a
certain distribution and say that look
this region we can't really hope to get
both your muscles and accuracy right
that is a very nice idea we certainly
have not looked at it but i yeah i i
think that could be really nice and
promising
um
yeah
thank you